[Música]
en nuestra sección directo
vamos a ciudad de méxico desde allí y
nuestro corresponsal mario carbonell
tiene todos los detalles de la más
reciente decisión del gobierno de andrés
manuel lópez obrador y es que la
administración federal se unió con más
de 30 empresas y presentaron un plan
para combatir la elevada inflación
especialmente de la canasta básica el
gobierno sostiene que no es un control
de precios sino una serie de medidas
para asegurar que por ejemplo los
alimentos tengan un precio justo en
medio de la inflación más alta que se ha
visto en mexico en 21 años
-mario bienvenido a france 24 un placer
de nuevo conversar con ustedes empecemos
por hablar de cuáles son esas medidas
del plan porque entendemos que van desde
el aumento de producción agrícola hasta
subsidios a la gasolina
así es contiene varias medidas una de
ellas es precisamente mantener los
precios de gasolina y diésel que no
aumentarán pero también se aumentará en
2 millones de toneladas la producción de
granos básicos como arroz maíz y frijol
para evitar la escasez y que no suban
los precios asimismo se aumentará de 5 a
9 estados los que recibirán apoyos de
fertilizantes para los cultivos entre
otras medidas también habrá el fijo los
precios para los peajes de las
carreteras para que no aumenten tampoco
los costos de la cadena de distribución
y se incrementará la seguridad también
en las vías de comunicación para evitar
robos y que esto también impacte en los
precios y también se aplicará una medida
de cero aranceles para los productos y
los insumos básicos de importación con
estas medidas el gobierno pretende que
los 24 productos de la canasta básica no
aumenten su precio y ayudar a los
trabajadores -mario y en medio de todas
esas medidas cuál es el papel de los
empresarios y qué empresas reconoce de
méxico respaldan el plan
bueno hay empresas como las de carlos
slim- que son telmex y telcel que se
comprometieron a no aumentar los precios
de telefonía y servicios de interés en
lo que es de internet perdón lo que
resta del año asimismo está bimbo que se
comprometió a mantener los precios del
pan blanco sin aumentos está también más
seca que provee para las tortillas de
maíz y también tiendas departamentales
grandes cadenas como wal mart soriana y
chedraui
los empresarios se comprometen a que
cada uno evaluará en qué porcentaje
hasta un 20% pueden reducir los precios
de sus productos y cuáles también se
comprometieron a que esto no irá en
detrimento de la calidad de los
productos pues ésta se mantendrá ya que
el objetivo es cerrar filas para evitar
que siga en la escalada de precios que a
nadie conviene fueron varios empresarios
incluidos también las cúpulas de los
organismos empresariales como el consejo
coordinador empresarial y la comisión
patronal de la república mexicana el
presidente dijo que si bien esto no es
la solución completa problema si es una
manera de ayudar a que los precios no
aumenten y una forma de no quedarse de
brazos cruzados este plan durará por lo
menos seis meses y se irá evaluando en
conjunto con los órganos empresariales
para ver qué ajustes se le pueden hacer
a estas medidas ya miraremos si esto es
suficiente para frenar la escalada de
precios que como usted dice no le
conviene a nadie gracias mario por estar
con nosotros